c'était il y a deux ans el chapo venait
de poser le pied sur le sol américain
il n'en repartira sans doute jamais à
moins de s'évader de prison
une troisième fois une vie qui ressemble
à un film d'action
nous sommes ici avec les forces
spéciales mexicaines
ce sont ces soldats qui vont finir par
mettre la main sur joaquín guzmán dit el
chapo un surnom qui veut dire le petit
lui qui est en fait l'un des plus grands
narcotrafiquants c'était lui qui tirait
toutes les ficelles commandité
assassinats et enlèvement
pendant son règne le cartel mexicain de
sinaloa a exporté des centaines de
tonnes de cocaïne d'héroïne de cannabis
par sous marin dans des boîtes de piment
ou des bananes en plastique à son procès
ses anciens lieutenants ont décrit un
chef sanguinaire qui corrompent est tout
ce qu'il pouvait son spécialiste des
communications a détaillé le système de
cryptage sophistiqué qui l'utilisé mais
il y avait d'autres systèmes plus
basiques comme cette porte en métal
elle a fait perdre 8 précieuses minutes
lors d'une tentative d'arrestation en
résultat bénéfices porte rab el chapo a
le temps de s'enfuir par un tunnel sous
sa baignoire
tout comme on le voit ici disparaître de
sa cellule au mexique en 2015
sa deuxième évasion là aussi un tunnel
d'un kilomètre et demi a été creusé sous
la douche avec une moto sur des rails
qui l'attendait en dessous
blanchiment d'argent participation à une
organisation criminelle importations de
155 tonnes de drogue aux états unis
el chapo est reconnu coupable des 10
chefs d'accusation il risque la prison à
vie mais ses avocats n'en resteront pas
là
on connaîtra la peine qui lui sera
infligée le 25 juin ici mathieu prost
radio canada